the shining plus the Lord of the Flies
plus the labyrinth - the humor The Maze
Runner so since all of us were begging
and salivating for yet another young
adult novel to be transitioned to the
big screen we have the Maze Runner
this is hollywood's new thing for sure
young adult books being transitioned to
the big screen i mean ever since Harry
Potter and Twilight exploded every book
ever that was written for a teen
audience that is even remotely popular
is going to be on the big screen The
Maze Runner tells the tale of a group of
kids who are locked in this small little
area it's all trees all forests they
have to learn how to build everything
themselves they don't know why they're
there their memories are erased of their
past but around this small forest-like
enclosure is a gigantic maze filled with
these things called grievers they're all
very fearful of going into this maze
even though they know that's the only
way they can escape there are selected
few people called runners who as you
would expect are very good at running
who are allowed to run through the maze
and figure out its various inner
workings and when her main character
Thomas arrives he starts changing things
for the better because there's just
something different about him you may
have noticed earlier I was sort of
talking crap about young adult novels
being transitioned to the big screen
because that is what is happening
nowadays it seems like there's one every
week I mean we just had the giver a few
weeks ago and so I walked into this
movie very skeptical because lately a
lot of these just feel like cash grabs
gracefully for a large portion of this
movie it didn't feel that way at all I
actually thought this was a pretty well
directed movie with a very good lead
performance by young Dylan O'Brien who I
thought was excellent in the movie the
movie opens very intense he's on this
elevators leading up to this place and
all of a sudden all these young kids are
looking at him he has no idea where he
is and he has to learn all the rules of
this area he's making new friends and
then the maze sequences are actually
very impressive and a little bit
suspenseful these griever creatures I
like that stuff a lot even though the
CGI was a little obvious from time to
time some aspects of The Maze Runner
particularly the first two acts I really
liked will Poulter is particularly
really good in this movie you may
remember him from we're the Millers
where he played a more comedic role he
was actually really great in this movie
and so was dylan o'brien as i said and
their adversary like relationship
definitely added something to this movie
that being said is this movie drew to a
close I thought it lost a lot I really
kind of hated the ending of this movie
and there is a very common defense that
I hear for things like this people say
while it's in the book it's in the book
so I mean it's fine right no this is a
film a filmmaker adapting certain pieces
of a book just because they're in the
book doesn't necessarily mean it works
in the movie the book is its own thing
if the book works that's great but it's
the filmmakers job to make it work for
the big screen and I didn't think
certain aspects of the way this film
ended worked at all in fact there is the
imposed obvious we're going to have a
sequel set up scene than I've ever
witnessed I think there's a line that's
said by a character that sets up this
whole sequel thing that's the most
obvious thing ever the guy sitting
behind me went ah it just felt so out of
place I felt like Norm Macdonald from
Billy Madison was all of a sudden there
and he was just like oh yeah it is gonna
be another one my other big problem with
the movie is actually the big ending
when you finally find out what's
happening why everyone can't remember
things what they're doing there
it was very predictable I predicted it
from the very beginning it was like the
first thing I thought of the first
rational thing I thought of for why it's
all happening that's why it's happening
and then certain ways that they
explained it were the most far-fetched
things that completely took me out of
the movie-going experience it doesn't
matter to me if that's the way it was in
the novel this is a film I'm critiquing
the film not the book and the movie just
did not make it work it didn't make it
plausible it didn't make it believable
it really sucked me out of the more
realistic experience that I had had up
to that point that being said the movie
does look good there are some really
good running chase sequences the
director has a very swift look for this
movie and it looks very sleek and it
feels fresh a lot of the time but the
drama and the stakes didn't feel real
enough they didn't feel high enough and
towards the third act the way it ended
just really deflated it for me I'm gonna
give the Maze Runner a C+ I like the
first in the second act Dylan O'Brien
was good in the movie as his will
poulter it's a good looking movie but
the third act just really went south for
me unfortunately so guys let me know
what you thought of the Maze Runner book
or the movie if you've seen it already
what's your opinion on this whole young
adult novel to big screen thing of Fifty
Shades of Grey which isn't even a young
adult novel and that's coming up what's
happening oh man I'm probably
have to watch that too guys I also want
to give a big thanks to Hulu Plus comm
for sponsoring this video and for
continuing to sponsor my channel I
really really appreciate that if you
guys go to Hulu Plus comm slash Chris
Tuchman you can get two weeks of Hulu
Plus for free
my gift to you through Hulu it's that
easy I'm just giving you guys two weeks
of the loop plus for free because you
guys are awesome definitely check them
out they're getting this South Park
library this September how incredibly
awesome is that
they have tons of original content The
Criterion Collection on Hulu Plus is
astounding it's really cool for film
lovers like you and me go to Hulu Plus
comm slash Chris Duckman you can get two
weeks of Hulu Plus for free my gift to
you
also really quick something that I've
been doing lately for you guys on my
Twitter is giving away digital copies of
movies that I have because I just want
to give things to you guys seriously
like you guys have done so much for me
the least I can do is every once in a
while give away a digital copy I've
already given away V for Vendetta and
the talented mr. Ripley and right now
I'm giving away my digital copy of the
raid to one of the best action movies
this year so far all you gotta do is go
to my Twitter and retweet this tweet and
follow me that's simple I want to give
things to my viewers like you guys are
awesome and you really do mean a lot to
me and I thank you for that
as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck min eyes
Oh